i am black now so waiting for him
okay let's go for sicilian again
okay what was that second move i forgot
you found
e4 c5 my f3 knight c6 c3
yeah i think so okay so it's not nothing
special here
i can go b5 before
wait oh the second move was kingi too
really huh
so he tried to play bang clown okay
okay that's interesting let's go
before okay let's go
so he tried to confuse me with the
position of this king
and then yeah maybe he confused himself
now i'm gonna attack him
okay take the bishop
now what
it's not so easy here it is
i still have to prove my advantage not
so simple
but his skin is not safe there
[Music]
on e2 so at some point he has to
do something about that
f1 okay let's go h6 keep making safe
okay okay maybe i should go e6
and d5 maybe that's a good idea
i don't know could be maybe my knight
can come back to e7
okay i think i'm better here
but the position is so strange maybe
it's hard to remember
let's find a7 defending the partner g6
and also preparing for d5
now what is he going to do
nice two okay let's change
let's go d5
okay it's weakening so much his position
now
i don't think he will survive this
okay take my leg is coming to f4
totally over
his pawn i think is on g4 right not on
g3 so let's go there
yeah the fact is thinking means that the
pawn is not on g3 which is a good thing
for us
otherwise i'm losing a knight
now i can take that pawn on b3
attacking both the ropes if i'm not if
i'm not mistaken
and
let's take the rook on b1
and then maybe go to e8 and then i'm
gonna go
ready three next move
let's go 93 here and then queen takes g3
the pawn is on h3 and g4 so i think
that's good
okay there's something hanging on f3
so i can take that too and then i can go
let's just go game seven
yeah good game good game